hey uh you might be excited to learn
Carrie Lake who lost her race to be the
Arizona governor she now has a lawsuit
she has a lawsuit ladies and gentlemen
she appeared on the Steve Bannon real
America's voice War Room program I still
don't even know what that is but listen
to this Insanity a friend of mine texted
me two days ago
he said he lives in Arizona said I was
in Arizona at my local
uh car mechanic place getting my car
tuned up and in the waiting room they
had Steve bannon's show on
mind blown I have never heard of such a
thing okay Steve bannon's show Trump
attorney Christina Bob is there
and Carrie lake is there
and Kerry Lake declares they are ready
to go with a lawsuit
now what is the lawsuit going to do I
have no idea
the election in Arizona was certified
yesterday Kerry Lake lost Katie Hobbs
will be the governor but folks they have
a lawsuit is this a grift let's see if
we can figure it out how possibly can a
republican attorney general sit there
and a governor sit there and allow this
Fiasco people in Arizona have to
understand some Independence and
Democrats you look like idiots on the
world stage this looks like something
that would happen in the worst of banana
Republic's Kerry Lake yeah before she
answers
one of the worst things that could
happen is a candidate who didn't win
ending up in office unfortunately that's
not going to happen because this
lawsuit's not going to go anywhere but
let's listen to it
yeah I mean the Optics and just a little
over an hour the Optics of them
um sitting there and signing their
signature can you imagine to this sham
election they did it back in 2020 two
years ago and many of us gasped and said
how could they do this why couldn't they
give more time to look into all of the
issues now fast forward 22. remember
there's never been enough time the audit
wasn't done correctly the recount wasn't
appropriate there was barbecue sauce on
the ballots and they still counted you
know two today and we've got more issues
than we saw in 2020 and that sham
election we have just a blatant
sabotaging of election day a disrespect
a disregarded disenfranchisement of
election day voters none of this is true
and if they sit there and sign their
names to this sham Certification history
will never forgive them they will go
down as as three of the very worst in
history yeah it was signed Katie jobs is
officially the Arizona governor-elect
and she will be Kerry Lake's Governor
very soon
now that we know and by the way we're at
the top of the first thing to get into
the bottom of the FBI the uh doj and I
think CIA involvement intelligence
apparatus and law enforcement Steve
Bannon thinks now that the CIA is also
involved these people's brains are
filled with mayonnaise and by the way
pretty bad mayonnaise I would say
freshman apparatus involvement in the
coup d'etat in the 2020 election because
remember ladies and gentlemen they all
knew we had the receipts this is the
thing you have to understand we were
wiretapped they read our emails all of
it they knew we had the goods they knew
this is not just about a corrupt and
incompetent media it's about this in
2020 how does the Elon Musk now remember
and Bannon almost just jumping around
frenetically between topics the entire
they wiretapped us they spied on us
understand what happened it's really
simple what happened the Trump campaign
was in touch
in 2016
with so many suspected criminals who
themselves were being surveilled by law
enforcement
that the people on the Trump side of the
conversations were incidentally uh
surveilled in that way it's sort of like
if I right now as part of doing my show
regularly spoke to say organized crime
people
the organized crime people are under
surveillance
would it be accurate for me to say the
FBI is spying on me no what's happening
is I'm talking to so many suspects of
the organized crime investigation my
side of the conversation is getting
picked up by the FBI that's what
happened
ask the release of this what's happening
on about President Trump's 2020 tied
directly to what's going on in 2022 in
Arizona ma'am
well I mean to watch what happened over
the weekend I think what what musk put
out the information he put out I think
it was a game changer and to watch these
silence on the part of the mainstream
media no silence it's just there's not
much of a story there it was revenge
porn and the Biden Campaign which was
not the government at the time tried to
have it removed so listen Katie Hobbs
will be the governor of Arizona that's
the good news if Kerry Lake continues
living in Arizona Katie Hobbs will be
Carrie Lake's Governor period that's the
story they had the audacity yesterday
yes to certify an election for Katie
Hobbs that Katie Hobbs won that's good
news Kerry Lake didn't win if Kerry Lake
somehow ended up Governor that would be
a very bad thing and it's disturbing
that we have to explain this to people
the person who got more votes should be
the governor it would be bad for
democracy if the loser still got to be
Governor it would be
aversion
of the participation trophies that these
very same people claim to be against one
of our sponsors today is Bluetooth a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use use the promo code Pacman all
you have to do is pay five dollars
shipping